[Music]
so methane is uh
80 times more powerful than carbon
dioxide
over a 20-year period
it is a powerful greenhouse gas
and is responsible for 25
of the warming we're seeing today uh if
we could
reduce methane emissions
by 45
this decade
we will be able to reduce 0.3 degrees of
global warming for
the next 20 to 30 years
i have a thermal imaging camera that has
been designed
to specifically
visualize methane emissions
and so the camera it's it's an infrared
camera it works on the infrared spectrum
so it's filtered to see methane
emissions methane is invisible to the
naked eye we don't see it everywhere if
we saw it i think a lot more people
would be concerned
about the pollution that i'm seeing
i visited approximately 55 sites in
romania and
saw methane emissions at almost all of
them
romania has a significant amount of oil
and gas production
and
we're seeing more and more investments
into the oil and gas industry in romania
and there are plans to increase
production
romania's
oil and gas infrastructure is quite old
even if you just look at some of the
digital photos that i've taken you see
large rusted holes in the sides of
storage tanks those storage tanks are
still in use
in some of the
optical gas imaging photos i've taken
you can see emissions from storage tanks
as well as
venting from
relief pipes with the clean air task
force what we want to do
is document and observe these emissions
and raise the awareness of
methane pollutant in the atmosphere
[Music]